[Music]
depending on where you watch a cartoon
it may look completely different from
the way it looks in other countries
animators change important features and
graphics to appeal to viewers all across
the globe and we're here to show you
just how much these cartoons have been
altered if you're new to our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up because
today we're sharing 10 cartoons that
look different in other countries Toy
Story 2 in the 1999 film Toy Story 2
Buzz Lightyear gives a speech in front
of Ang's toys while in American flag
waves and the star-spangled banner plays
in the background but for international
audiences they didn't see this same
image
Pixar replaced the flag with a spinning
globe to make it more Universal and the
star-spangled banner was replaced by a
song created by composer Randy Newman
called the one-world anthem inside out
the adventure film inside out has a
scene where Riley's dad is trying to
feed her a spoonful of broccoli as she
turns her head and disgust but picks our
animators knew this scene wouldn't make
sense globally since broccoli isn't
considered gross in Japan having Riley
turned her head when offered this
vegetable wouldn't make sense in the
Asian market so animators change the
broccoli to green peppers fresh Japan
audience another image that was altered
as when a hockey scene is playing out in
Riley's dad's mind for international
audiences they inserted a soccer scene
instead because soccer is more popular
in other parts of the world Toy Story 3
in Toy Story 3 animators made many
changes to the original film to appeal
to the Russian market in the opening
scene when the title flashes across the
screen
animators change the title so that it
reads in Russian Cyrillic all throughout
the film the English alphabet was
replaced by Russian letters to make the
cartoon feel more authentic in that
market for a toy in the 2007 film
ratatouille the animated movie looks
different depending on where you live in
the US version of the film you'll notice
English words appear on the folder
newspaper and the letter in this scene
but in the version that was created for
friends all of the writing was converted
to French this just goes to show you how
much thought and effort is put into
animated films so they are relatable to
different audiences wreck-it Ralph in
the film wreck-it Ralph the racer minty
Zaki was created and named after
film animator hiya Miyazaki so for the
Japanese version of the film Minty's
last name is change in Sakura and her
entire image received a makeover even
though she's a minor character in the
film animators still decided to switch
up her look with red lip gloss short
green hair with fringe bangs flared
bangs on either side of her face and a
bun drizzled in chocolate up up is the
2009 adventure film released by Disney
and just like the rest of the movies on
our list it was changed a bit to reflect
different markets in the scene where
Elly is showing her adventure book the
book was translated into different
languages depending on where the film
would be shown and when it came to the
money jar it was labeled with Paradise
Falls for the English version of the
film but animators didn't want to
translate this saying into different
languages and from the risk of losing
its meaning so instead the letters were
scrapped and an image that can be
understood on a global level with use
instead Pokemon in this scene from the
cartoon Pokemon animators one of the
characters to appeal to the show's
english-speaking audience there's a
scene where misty ash and Brock are
talking about eating on you Judy a
popular Japanese snack that's covered
with rice and seaweed but for the
English audience they kept the image of
the oniony in the scene but the
characters referred to the treats as
jelly filled donut instead monsters
University in a scene from monsters
University where Randy makes a batch of
cupcakes the dessert spells out the word
be my pal in the English version of the
film but in international versions picks
our animators went with smiley faces
instead it would have been way too hard
for them to translate the words in every
language especially since the number of
letters is different in various dialects
so they went with the universal smiley
face instead and it worked out great
plains the character Rachelle looks
completely different depending on where
you watch planes she has a different
color and sometimes even a different
name in the US the racer is pink red and
white and in Australia she's red green
yellow black and white with a kangaroo
on her side in China her name is Yun
yang Fei and she's red yellow and white
and in Germany her name is Heidi and
she's white black yellow and red
Zootopia
American culture is pretty well
understood in most areas of the world
but
animators still made subtle changes to
Zootopia to bridge the cultural gap in
other parts of the world the movie is
actually entitled to tropi with the
movies fictional news channels vnn shows
two newscasters a snow leopard and a
moose in the US Canada and France but in
Japan the moose is replaced by a raccoon
dog in Australia and New Zealand viewers
see a koala bear instead China sees a
panda bear
Brazil sees a Jaguar and the UK audience
sees a Welsh Corgi were you surprised to
see how different cartoons look in other
countries let us know in the comment
section down below and if you enjoyed
this video please give it a big thumbs
up
[Music]